into mo what's that mo who are you
calling from
I'm coming from Belgium Belgium I love
it
awesome how can I help man we are app
developers but we don't call them itself
we are we had a great idea
we came up with a great idea it's our
social tip and app and we working on it
like to 82 years you have a company we
develop the app everything now is good
and well on 12 October we are doing a
product launch in a very nice club in
Belgium but now we are stuck with a
little problem and the problem is that
the Facebook API for Egan's
it's not working like like it used to
work okay it has changed you are
searching all websites and other apps
who who are glad to work with us so we
can't get the date the date out or the
post events this impacts your entire
company right it's not just your launch
event this is the entire company this is
your entire functionality yeah the EP of
Facebook has changed out so you can get
any data of events from Facebook what we
used to do because when people log in
with Twitter account they have login
with the Facebook account and and of
this way we get there we get their
events and put it in our app and then we
we organize those events for the people
it depends on where they are we really
need the data and we don't have it now
and we don't know when when paid when
Facebook is going to open it you never
know like they may open it up again or
they may not so with every business you
gotta assess your vulnerabilities this
happens over and over and over again
when you build your business on the back
of a big company like if YouTube went
away and the fact that if I couldn't
posted YouTube anymore that would be bad
for me like I've built my brand and my
business on the back of a big company
it wouldn't be crippling like I'd have
to go back and I'll go hardcore on
Instagram and wherever else people are
going
you you either have to make a big pivot
to something else or you've got to find
a way to get the data like if there's
another way I don't know enough about
the Facebook API but if there's another
way to get the data you hack you figure
out your way through it's a constant
adjustment or you make a bigger pivot
your business will be constantly at the
mercy of Facebook and so do you want to
be in that business or not yeah that's
that's true yes whoo yeah we never knew
that that that this was going to happen
but no one knows as and they'll say they
all say yeah it could be good not so I
thought I'm gonna ask even yeah I mean I
wish I had the end I've been do enough
with Facebook I think for that kind of
stuff it's great but for what I do
Facebook is not the place to be so I
don't have a lot of time there I don't
have anything else to tell you about
Facebook cuz I'm not I'm not in the
Facebook ecosystem I'm not developing
I'm not using their API I don't know
that it would come back though like if
I'm you I would be preparing a plan for
if I never get this data what do I do
with my company and then even if we get
even if you get it back it may not be
fully the full functionality that you
had before and at any time Facebook can
change their their rules like that's
part of the truck you haven't signed an
agreement that you get the data for five
years or anything right so they could
change it whenever they want and
everybody gets screwed over I've had a
lot of friends of mine who for both
Instagram - Instagram and Facebook the
the data limit has really hurt their
business and they're starting to make
other plans for what like how they can
evolve their business model so that's
not so dependent in facebook does come
back great
I wouldn't expect it though to be the
same level that you had before and then
how do you pivot the company if it's a
big pivot to something completely
different or just a small pivot that you
can you can like can you hack your way
through it or not it's it's it's forever
and ever the situation when you depend
on one big supplier and the supplier
changes it's every industry yeah we
really trusted that supplier with pizza
but that that's impossible to happen
because Facebook also make money of that
and also make make his name go go around
with a lot of apps they're losing money
though because of the the image right
like they can't have Cambridge
analytical happen again so this is why
it's happening but but you need to move
as soon as possible from a place of like
you start off you're complaining you're
angry like why did this happen
frustration two years of working on this
thing and and now we're finally ready
and then and it makes elegant hurts it's
real it hurts but the longer you stay in
that mindset it doesn't help you get
anywhere so it's like can we fix this
problem is there a way through it how
long we willing to wait and then having
a potential move on to something else if
you're not like if it's still like this
in six months are you still doing this
business we're gonna move to something
else or a different version of it using
different API is you use the meetup API
or you use some other API
working on it our developers are already
working on it yeah it really starts but
yeah that's part of the game you know
and there is there even a model like is
is Meetup is that API even enough do you
get enough data is it valuable enough or
not like it's Facebook so big that it
was witty enough yet it was it was
really awesome I mean we got like 200
people on our app just for testing the
app and to know how I would have it
works and and with 200 people we got so
much data it was not it was really
awesome a lot of developers in Belgium
contact us like guys how do you get
alright how do you get so much data but
it was really helpful yes Facebook is
not saying anything they may never say
anything so you need to figure out how
long you willing to wait for them to
give you some kind of answer and if it's
never like is it you give yourself three
months or six months or two weeks or one
day and then you have to move on to
something else
right I don't have any inside
information to share with you but
they're being super like I don't know
anybody who knows anything else either
like my friends who
in the business they don't know anything
either about if they're gonna get the
data or when so it's hurting a lot of
companies and it's obviously reason why
they're doing it so I just let's just
figure out what your timeline is like
how long can you how long you willing to
wait on facebook and and being able to
move on from it if they never give you
the data just having that mindset we
don't we don't we are not waiting we are
all ready
api's but it really it would be it would
be really good it would come back of
course dude of course I would love you
know I want to be 10 years younger and
and you know of course of course so but
you know like hope hope is not a
strategy no that's right right
cool man okay good luck man I got it I
got to leave but thank you for calling
in and best of luck with your launch in
Belgium thank you thank you also if you
want to know what I think and what other
successful entrepreneurs think about
building confidence check out my new 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days for free I will
send you a 30 second a five minute video
in the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be kind of like a little
beacon if you want to learn more about
marketing check out the video I made on
the top five marketing books or
entrepreneurs it's right there next to
me I think you'll like it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
then we're gonna hear from the authors
about what's inside the book to give you
a little bit more Khan